you kind of are the ultimate cool girl
like you're just fun and I didn't love
that more than when I saw you at can and
you were snatched from head to toe and
then had your flip-flops on thank you
for bringing this up I would really like
to straighten this out I was not making
a political statement not that like I
wouldn't like I totally agree with I had
no idea that there was like a whole
controversy with people wearing flats or
like walking down the red carpet
Barefoot I had no clue I wore heels
going up and I knew I would eat if I
went down and the shoes that were size
too big everybody's like what everyone
is statement wow I'm all for making a
statement I just would want it to be
like on purpose I just thought Jennifer
she's just like us like she couldn't
wear those shoes it's true though you
are she's just like her feet bloat When
She Flies